And there are many examples of this;...
....I think of perhaps another and then let's pull these things together.
When Volkswagen and the chief executive was really bidding against BMW for Rolls-Royce,...
...the bidding got significant.
Unfortunately the intellectual property, the name Rolls-Royce and some other elements...
...was actually owned by a third party, who wouldn't talk to either Volkswagen or BMW.
Volkswagen CEO did the deal, paid for Rolls-Royce and only then turned to the negotiation...
...with the intellectual property owner...
...who owned the name Rolls-Royce and some key design elements.
Imagine how that negotiation was set up.
If you were re - doing it, you'd reverse the sequence...
...and have a very different kind of deal design.
What I'm suggesting is that in many, many cases, you need to think away from the table.
Have you got the right parties?
How's the no deal options?
Has the sequence and basic process plan been well thought out...
...and put you in an advantageous as opposed to a disadvantageous situation?
So setup, deal design and tactics are all dimensions that you want working for you.
When you're trying to create as much value as you can,...
...end up with a full share of that and do it for the long term.